today on the show we're gonna talk about
the corona virus and I'm probably like
you I I don't know what exactly to think
about all of this it's it's overwhelming
it's confusing it is pretty scary and so
we're just we're gonna we're gonna try
to talk it out sift through the facts
and the fictions and the myths and
everything surrounding this I'll tell
you what some of the experts are saying
I'm not an expert so I can't speak with
any expertise but I can tell you at
least what some of them are saying and
we'll try to figure out what our
approach should be and our response
should be to to all this that's coming
up also five headlines including Canada
trying to ban so-called conversion
therapy is that a good idea I think it
is definitely not and I'll explain why
and in your daily cancellation remember
the woman who was on may the hilarious
math mistake on MSNBC a few days ago
well she got she got a lot of a lot of
grief for that people making fun of her
which is gonna happen in the Internet
age but she's she's not happy about it
and she's come back and you'll never
guess you'll never guess what directions
she she decided to take it she says that
you're racist if you made fun of her for
it and so we're gonna talk about that as
well all of that and more on the way but
first as I said I want to talk about the
corona virus and tried to sift through
this there's been a lot of focus on the
panic the mass hysteria and I've talked
about that too but I'm beginning to
think that we're worried about panic are
we getting to the point where actually
massive denial is is more the problem
have we been so focused on stopping
people from panicking that we have been
maybe unintentionally encouraging denial
and is that becoming the bigger issue my
thinking on this has shifted I will
fully admit that and it's hard for me to
say that my thinking has changed
completely
because or they say that I've changed my
mind completely because I you know I'm
in the same boat as a lot of you I I
don't know exactly what to think there's
a lot of information
a lot of people screaming from every
side of this thing a lot of people
trying to exploit it for political
reasons or for ratings or for whatever
else there are many pundits and
commentators like myself who are very
desperate to have the best take on the
issue so I just want to as I said talk
through some of this and I do that with
the disclaimer again repeated that I am
no expert at all on this not that you'd
be tempted to take me it was one
hopefully but but just to be clear what
I'm doing right now this is like the
conversation that you're having in your
living room with your family and friends
about this conversations I've had with
people about this I'm not sitting here
teaching you about the virus let me
teach you about how pandemics work no
what the hell do I know
we're just as I said talking through it
and seeing if we can't find a little bit
of clarity just just a bit amid amid the
confusion now to begin with let's get
some updates on this thing starting with
President Trump giving a address from
The Oval Office last night announcing
some rather dramatic steps that are
justified steps I think including a
travel ban from Europe after consulting
with our top government health
professionals I have decided to take
several strong but necessary actions to
protect the health and well-being of all
Americans to keep new cases from
entering our shores we will be
suspending all travel from Europe to the
United States for the next 30 days the
new rules will go into effect Friday at
midnight these restrictions will be
adjusted subject to conditions on the
ground there will be exemptions for
Americans who have undergone appropriate
screenings and these prohibitions will
not only apply to the tremendous amount
of Trade and cargo but various other
things as we get approval anything
coming from Europe to the United States
is what we are discussing these
restrictions will also not apply to the
United Kingdom at the same time we are
monitoring the situation in China in the
South Korea and as their situation
improve
we will reevaluate the restrictions and
warnings that are currently in place for
a possible early opening of course Trump
is being attacked by the Democrats for
this yada yada I'm not really interested
in getting into the politics of it
yeah the Democrats are trying to make
this in they were complaining Trump's
not doing enough and now they're
complaining that he's doing too much
it's too draconian and strict to
restrict travel from Europe they're
obviously wrong about that but I don't
want to make that the focus I think
that's a mistake for to make that the
focus to try to use the coronavirus
let's talk about how the Democrats are
wrong about the coronavirus I mean they
are wrong but a lot of other people are
wrong too and that's not really the
point that's not what's gonna keep us
safe and you know as it's not the most
important thing to us and our families I
don't think in this so so that's that's
not what we're gonna discuss I think the
measure makes sense it's good this is
what we need to do but there are two
things in response to it or reaction to
it that I want to say one is that it's
too late of course to keep the virus out
of our country completely it's good to
prevent more sources of it from entering
so that's why I think this is a good
thing to do but it's here already
obviously so our primary focus would
seem it would seem that it needs to be
on measures that we can take within our
country to fight it Trump did not
address or focus on that very much in
his speech you focus on it a little bit
but not not nearly enough I was hoping
to hear a lot more about it including
testing because right now one of the
biggest problems we have is that not
very many people have been tested for it
and it's difficult to get a test if you
think you need one we should be testing
everyone who might even remotely have
come in contact with it that's what
South Korea did and we'll get back to
South Korea in a moment meanwhile the
NBA has chosen to suspend its season
another drastic step that will result in
massive losses of income not just for
the wealthy basketball players and the
officials and the owners but think about
the working-class people that work at
the stadiums the concession stand they
work at the gift shop
even the
restaurants around the arena's in these
cities many of them rely on that foot
traffic on game day to stay afloat how
many of them are gonna go under because
of things like this
lots of lost money lots of lost jobs and
this is just the start of it all so it
was reported yesterday that Tom Hanks
and his wife have coronavirus they were
shooting a movie in Australia I believe
and now now they have it they're
reportedly doing doing well though and
doctor foul Qi director of the National
Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Diseases this is all stuff that happened
yesterday with car alarms that's why I'm
going through all of it now doctor foul
Qi by all accounts very a reliable
non-political person was talking to a
congressional committee yesterday about
the disease and this is how he tried to
explain the lethality of it especially
relative to something like the flu
doctor Falchi can you by way of
comparison briefly explain what's how
does Co vat19 compared to other previous
health situations SARS h1n1 okay sure
sir thank you for the question well SARS
was also a corona virus in 2002 it
infected 8,000 people and it killed
about 775 it had a mortality of about 9
to 10 percent so that's only 8,000
people in about a year in the two and a
half months that we've had this corona
virus as you know we now have multiple
multiples of that so it clearly is not
as lethal and I'll get to the lethality
in a moment but it certainly spreads
better probably for the practical
understanding of the American people the
seasonal flu that we deal with every
year has a mortality of 0.1 percent the
stated mortality overall of this when
you look at all the data including China
is about three percent at first started
off as two and now three I think if you
count all the cases of minimally
symptomatic or asymptomatic infection
that probably brings the mortality rate
down to somewhere
around 1% which means it is 10 times
more lethal than the seasonal flu so the
good news is that the mortality rate
isn't as high as has been reported the
two or three percent probably not that
high the bad news is according to him
and most other medical experts that I've
read it's at least still - still 10
times deadlier than the flu and the flu
is all these comparisons to the flu and
people saying and I've said this too
that at least early on I was using this
comparison which I've come to see is not
exactly legitimate or at least not very
helpful but this comparison to the flu
trial you know it's just the flu the flu
is already a serious illness I just had
the flu it's it's that's it's not a walk
in the park by any means and when if
you've actually gotten the flu you you
know when you have it you could kind of
tell how people die from this I'm not
saying that I was on my deathbed I
wasn't but you get very sick high fever
you could have some difficulty breathing
you got you're up coughing you feel like
you can't breathe things like that and
you can see how if somebody's elderly or
if they're young they got an underlying
medical condition you can see how that
this might result in some very serious
issues for them so the flu is a serious
illness to begin with now if you're
saying that it's ten times deadlier than
the flu which is what dr. Fauci just
said that should really make our ears
perk up I'm not saying it should make us
panic but that's something we need to
pay attention to when you got a man like
dr. Falchi telling you that about a
disease that's just entered this country
and is spreading exponentially as we
speak that's something I you can't just
waltz past that I don't think and we
hear one percent well one maybe the
death rate is one percent and we think
that's not so bad but first of all one
percent translated - you know if we're
talking about protect potentially many
thousands or even millions of cases one
percent of that is quite a lot and it's
growing exponentially we're at 1,300
cases right now report in cases that's
without much test
but it was only two weeks ago that
Donald Trump did a press conference you
might recall and said said it was it
goes exactly two weeks ago or two ends
days ago he said 15 cases and we're
expecting soon there will be no cases
fast-forward 14 15 days we have 1500
reported cases but on this issue of the
mortality rate just because you survive
an illness doesn't mean that it was a
mild case necessarily and then you came
out unscathed so let me read a little
bit of an article by James Hamblin who's
a doctor and lecturer at Yale School of
Public Health I think you need to hear
what he has to say and the whole article
is worth reading I'll read you a little
bit of it we'll get to that in just a
second but first I want to tell you
about our friends over at stamps calm
stamps calm those are going to the post
office especially these days going out
in public and and going to the post
office it's a hassle there are other
issues as well
manukan avoid it makes a lot of sense to
avoid it I would say so
that's why stamps.com exists there's
just no reason to go through though all
that hassle and everything else stamps
comm is completely online plus you save
5% off every first class stamp at up to
40% off shipping rates simply use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 for any letter any package any
class of mail anywhere you want to send
it to
once your mail is ready you just hand it
to your mail carrier drop it on your
mailbox it's as simple as that think
about how much time and money you could
have saved on letters and packages over
the years think about all the things you
could have done I could have finally
learned how to play that banjo behind me
if I if I had not spent so much time at
the post office with stamps calm you get
discounted postage rates that you can't
even get at the post office and there's
no equipment to lease and no long-term
commitments and it's just really that
simple it is a no-brainer you save time
you save money so right now my listeners
get a special offer that includes a four
week trial plus free postage and a
digital scale without any long-term
commitment go to stamps comm click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in Walsh that's stamps
comm answer Walsh
okay back to this article this is from
dr. James Hamlin he says kovat 19 is not
the flu we have a vaccine for the flu we
have antiviral medications design
to treat the flu we have a sense of what
to expect when we catch the flu and when
it's necessary to seek medical attention
doctors have experienced treating the
flu and tests to help diagnose the flu
right there in the office while you wait
against the new disease we have none of
this
this corona virus is unknown to our
species once it breaks into one of our
cells the extent of its spread through
the body seems to vary significantly the
experience can slowly progress from the
familiar cough congestion fever to a
life-threatening inflammatory response
as the virus spreads down into the lungs
filling the airwaves with fluid
survivors can have permanent scarring in
the lungs the virus can also spread into
other organs causing liver damage or
gastrointestinal disease these effects
can play out over longer periods than in
the flu sometimes waxing and waning some
patients have begun to feel better than
falling critically ill the disease can
be fatal despite receiving optimal
medical care I think that's important
important reference point important
context for this is it scary yeah but I
don't think we can just ignore it on
that basis or on the basis that it's
gonna make people panic another article
in the Atlantic by Johns Hopkins
professor provides more details he says
the first fact is that at least in the
initial stages documented cases of Kovan
19 seemed to increase in exponential
fashion on the 23rd of January China's
Hubei Province which contains the city
of Wuhan had 444 confirmed Cove in 19
cases a week later it had 4903
another week later by the sixth it had
22,000 112 the same story is now playing
out in other countries around the world
Italy had 62 cases on the 22nd of
February that had 888 cases by the 29th
4636 by the 6th of February because the
United States has been extremely
sluggish and testing patients for the
corona virus the official tally of 604
likely represents a fraction of the real
case load but even if we take this
number at face value it suggests that we
should prepare to have it up to 10 times
as many cases a week from today and up
to a hundred times as many cases two
weeks from today
the second fact is this disease is
deadlier than the flu to which the
honestly ill informed and the
irresponsible insist on comparing
early guesstimate made before data were
widely available suggested the fatality
rate for the coronavirus might wind up
being about one percent if that proves
true it's ten times as deadly as the flu
but there's reason to fear that the
fatality rate could be much higher
according to the World Health
Organization the current case fatality
rate a common measure of what portion of
confirmed patients die from at a
particular disease stands at 3.4 percent
that figure could be an overstatement
because mild cases of the disease are
less likely to be diagnosed or it could
be an understatement because many
patients have already been diagnosed
with the virus but have not yet
recovered and may still die so more more
facts and context there Michael
osterholm who's an epidemiologist was
interviewed on a Joe Rogan show the
other day it's about an hour-and-a-half
interview I'd recommend watching the
whole thing I did and I would also
recommend reading the entire the
entirety of both of the articles I just
read pieces of you can find both of them
in the Atlantic but let me play just
about a minutes of ulster home again an
epidemiologist he's an expert this is
what he does for a living this is him
talking about the corona virus and what
kind of threat it does or does not pose
to us how serious is this is this
something that we need to be terrified
of or is this overblown or how do you
stand on this well first of all you have
to understand the timing of it in the
sense that is just beginning and so in
terms of what hurt pain suffering death
is acount happened so far is really just
beginning this is going to unfold for
months to come yet and that's I think
what people don't quite yet understand
what we saw in China I'm convinced as
are many of my colleagues as soon as
they release all of these social
distances is mandated stay in homes
haven't left your home in weeks and
weeks kind of thing when they go back to
work they're on planes trains subways
buses crowded spaces manufacturing
plants even China is going to come back
again and so this really is acting like
an influenza virus something that
transmits very very easily through the
air we now have data to show that your
infectious before you even get sick and
in some cases quite highly infectious
just breathing is all that you need to
do so from this perspective I can
understand why people would say well
wait a minute
flu kills a lot more itself every year
than this does and are we remind people
this just was beginning probably the
best guesstimate we have right now on
what limited data we have to say this
could be at least 10 to 15 times worse
than the worst seasonal flu year we see
and there have been many articles and
interviews and so on with doctors
epidemiologists people who do this for a
living people who know the science not
pundits not talk radio hosts not podcast
host like myself but people who actually
know how this works
and most of them from what I have seen
with a few exceptions are saying things
like this they're not screaming it
they're not saying oh my God we're all
gonna die but there's saying this is
serious this is a big problem and this
is a serious illness and it is worse
than the flu and and it just is I'm
sorry but it is so I look at this and I
listen to it and I look at the fact that
governments have been quarantine whole
populations shutting down events taking
drastic steps costly steps absorbing
massive hits to their economy in order
to stop this I look at companies like
the NBA willingly losing millions if not
billions of dollars I look at the
numbers the numbers as I stand right now
exponential growth in the in the United
States Italy in such bad shape that
they're having to decide they're having
to decide which patients to treat and
which to let die and if you think that
could never happen here we'll also keep
in mind that we're also we're being
warned by health care professionals that
if there's a massive influx of people
who need medical treatment because of
this and I think the hospitalization
rate right now is about 10% which is
high if there's a massive influx we
don't have the capacity to treat all
those people right now we don't have
enough ventilators we don't have enough
hospital beds we don't have it and we
already know we don't have enough tests
so you look at all that and then South
Korea there are people who point to
South Korea for encouragement I I was
doing that myself I was looking at South
Korea while there containing this that's
that's encouraging maybe you know maybe
Italy's an outlier who knows
but South Korea took very dramatic steps
we have to keep that in mind decisive
and quick steps including they opened up
drive throughs where you could drive
through and get a test easy as that
don't even get out of your car they were
testing everybody they're doing about
15,000 tests a day we're doing we have
done total less than 7000 so they do
more we do half we've done half total of
what they do in a day just to put that
perspective they shut down big events
they practice very disciplined social
distancing they even according to Al it
to a Washington Post article I just read
the put GPS trackers on the infected
people anonymously so there are other
people and then that information was
available online you could go and find
out where the infected people are and
then avoid them now I'm not saying that
we should do that
I think there's serious privacy concerns
they're very serious I am saying that
before you feel too good about South
Korea realize they did things to stop
this that we are not doing some of which
we should do like mass testing I have a
friend who came here just this week flew
here from Israel and and he has cold
send symptoms no fever
he's probably fine probably just a cold
and he has you know he's got a runny
nose and things like and that's that as
far as I understand is not really a
symptom that is typical of Kovan 19 but
even so he's an international traveler
with with with you know flu-like
symptoms he should be able to get tested
he called up though they told him you
know you don't need to get tested call
us back if you have a fever maybe maybe
we'll help you out then that's not the
way it should be in South Korea he's
getting tested here doesn't get tested
so I look at all this and I begin to
suspect that my initial take was wrong
as much as I hate being wrong initially
I thought that this was media hype going
back a month ago when we first started
hearing all these reports there was
of global pandemics and I said my
reaction was yeah well here we go again
the media is always hyping up some
doomsday scenario some new apocalypse
some some vehicle of doom and
destruction they're always talking about
and then it always fizzles out whether
it's whether it's a pandemic or or
hurricane I mean how many times have we
seen this the boy who cried wolf right
but the point of the boy who cried wolf
story is that the wolf actually shows up
one day is this our wolf as the wolf
come I don't know
should we panic obviously not but I
don't think the I'm not sure if they
don't panic takes are really helpful at
this point and and I have shared those
takes as well I even wrote an article
about oh we shouldn't panic well yeah of
course we shouldn't panic everybody
everybody already knows that everybody
knows in theory that you shouldn't panic
it's not like anybody is suggesting
actual panic as a strategy or it's not
like anyone ever panics no one ever
makes a decision you know what I think I
should panic right now yeah that seems
like the right approach and then they
start panicking that's not the way it
works
so saying don't panic already is is
pretty useless everybody knows that it's
like saying to someone don't have road
rage now nope don't have it
you shouldn't have road rage well yeah
of course nobody thinks road rage is a
good strategy no one thinks no one is
pro road rage it happens because their
emotions get the best of them and it's
and I doubt that someone in the midst of
you they're about to explode in a road
rage event I don't think they're gonna
stop and say you know what did I hear
someone tell me once about how I
shouldn't have road rage oh yeah they
did tell ok so I think I won't
yeah we shouldn't panic fine but you
also shouldn't panic even if you're in a
really dire situation if you're if
you're drowning in shark-infested waters
you shouldn't panic then either panic is
not going to be helpful but that doesn't
mean that you're not an entire situation
and if somebody's shouting from the
shore don't panic
that's not gonna be a lot of help but
it's there's a fat lot of good that's
gonna do for you and in any case it
doesn't negate or minimize the fact that
you really are in a you know in a tough
spot
zombie apocalypse don't panic yeah sure
but it's still a zombie apocalypse now
I'm not saying that this is tantamount
to us all drowning in shark-infested
waters I'm not saying it's a zombie
apocalypse but I don't know if the if
the if we really need to keep telling
people not to panic
and besides are people actually
panicking over this some people are
panicking that they might run out of
toilet paper we've seen a few videos of
people fighting over toilet paper I
think that's not really panic over the
disease that's more panic that they're
gonna need toilet paper and not have it
I understand that panic well in fact
I've we have all in our lives had
panicky moments where you need some
toilet paper and can't find it so that I
can almost understand other than that I
don't see people running through the
streets with their hair on fire I don't
see it III think some people are
concerned very concerned I I'm in that
camp now I'm officially there the facts
on the ground as they stand right now I
think justify serious concern and now
what I'm starting to worry is that the
issue is less panic and more denial from
what this is all anecdotal but the
people talking about panic it's
anecdotal for them too so anecdotally
what I have seen denial is at this point
far more common than panic I haven't
actually seen or talked to anyone who's
legitimately panicking so I haven't met
that person I have met people and talked
to people who are in straight-up denial
about this any have to also think what
if we are in a pandemic situation which
the World Health Organization officially
declared a pandemic we
why do you what is more dangerous do you
think what's more dangerous to panic or
to be in complete denial to take too
many precautions or to take none what
I've what I've seen online especially a
lot of people saying this is all a media
hoax that's a real point of view that a
not insignificant portion of people seem
to have that this is either completely
invented by the media or they are hyping
it up to kingdom come
and it's really not a bad big deal it's
just a cold and they're trying to take
down Trump with it it may be true that
they're hyping it up and they want to
take down Trump but it's also true this
is a serious issue and that's why you
don't need to listen to Don Lemon or
Anderson Cooper about this or Chris
Cuomo okay listen to the epidemiologist
and the doctors unless they're gonna say
that all of them are also engaged in a
conspiracy to take down Trump then I
think we see that there is cause for
concern and III have seen someone just
yesterday I was talking to someone
online on Twitter and they said they
said you know I'm not worried about it
because for everybody 40 and under it's
harmless those the word they use
harmless harmless for people 40 and
under that is not true it's true that it
hasn't killed any children thank God
there are certain diseases that for
whatever reason don't really affect kids
although if kids are still carriers of
the disease and they're gonna bring it
to people who it will affect but it gets
it gets worse and worse it seems as you
get older so if you're in your 30s and
you get this you're probably not going
to die but you could and and there is a
and and it's you you could have even if
you don't die a very serious response to
it harmless but it seems like there are
those who are inventing comforting facts
about this to make themselves feel
better this is someone who just is
telling themselves oh it's harmless if
you're under 40 he just made that up no
doctor has said that no epidemiologist
no expert no health organization is said
that it's harmless for people under 40
that's just someone who's made it up and
I asked you what is what is a greater
danger and threat to your help to be
someone who thinks it's harmless or to
be someone who's too freaked out about
it I think we'd all do well to heed the
warning of trying to pull up this
article there was an article in Newsweek
written by a doctor in Western Europe
and a little bit of what he says says
I'm a doctor in a major hospital of
Western Europe watching you Americans
and you Brits in these still early days
of the corona virus pandemic it's like
watching a familiar horror movie where
the protagonist yet again split into
pairs or decide to take a tour of a dark
basement the real-life version of this
behavior is pretending this is just a
flu keeping schools open following
through with your holiday travel plans
going into the office daily this is what
we did in Italy we were so complacent
that even when people with coronavirus
symptoms started turning up we wrote
each off as a nasty case of the flu we
kept the economy going pointed fingers
at China urged tourists to keep
traveling and the majority of us told it
told ourselves and each other
this isn't so bad we're young we're fit
we'll be fine even if we catch it fast
forward two months and we are drowning
statistically speaking judging by the
curve in China we are not even at the
peak yet but our fatality rate is at
over 6% double the known global average
put aside statistics here's how it looks
in practice most of my childhood friends
are now doctors working in North Italy
in Milan they are having to choose
between intubating a 40 year old with
two kids a four year old who's fit and
healthy with no comorbidities and a six
year old with high blood pressure
because they don't have enough beds in
the hallway meanwhile there are another
15 people waiting who are hardly
breathing and need oxygen and he
continues from there the problem I think
and so you listen to people in Italy and
they look at the denial that we're in
right now some of us and they're saying
snap out of it right now because this is
coming for you yeah it's a different
kind of health care system yes Italy is
an older country but we're not
immortal right we're not superheroes we
ought we are humans we're mortal just
like that we're not impervious to
disease and viruses don't discriminate
but they don't care that it's America
and we're different
I don't think of virus recognizes that
the problem I think and I know this is
my issue even even now part of my issue
well part of my hesitation in taking
this as seriously as I probably should
is not knowing who to trust and I think
that's that's a big issue is it's a
crisis of trust there's so much
information out there we know there are
a lot of people lying a lot of people
with agendas and there's just so much of
it there's such an influx of information
for us now from so many different
sources
what do you trust well I feel fairly
safe trusting epidemiologists and
doctors and Health Organization's on the
topic of infectious diseases and
pandemics even the CDC and the World
Health Organization now I'm not going to
trust these organizations or these
people implicitly on every topic but on
the issue of infectious diseases
pandemics how viruses work well if I
don't trust them then who do I put above
them Who am I gonna trust instead of
them I'm not an expert on it I'm not
going out there into the field to do
research I'm not getting my microscope
out and studying this thing myself I'm
sure you're not either so you got to
trust somebody you have to get your
information from somewhere if you're not
gonna get it from these people who are
you getting it from cable news house
talk radio hosts well the other issue is
that it just doesn't feel real does it
for us right now right now for me I mean
I mean I hear I hear what they're saying
in Italy I saw China on the news I hear
about the measures they took in South
Korea I read the stories of quarantine
people getting sick and dying even in
this country even young healthy people I
read it I hear it I understand it but it
doesn't feel real because in my life
things look normal and and there's still
this thought in the back of my head that
no no you know this kind of stuff
doesn't this kind of stuff doesn't
happen anymore not here not in the
middle of my comfortable life pandemics
what is this the Middle Ages that's not
gonna happen
come it's 2020 don't be ridiculous now I
don't think that to myself explicitly I
don't literally think that it couldn't
happen here because for some reason it's
we've we've grown past it in modern
society but that's the attitude in the
back of my mind maybe you can relate in
fact I know that a lot of people can
relate based on the demeanor of so many
people and based on the people who are
still in spite of all the facts on the
ground and everything we're hearing from
experts on the subject still they insist
that this is nothing to worry about
based on what on what basis do they
waive all this stuff off I think it's on
the basis of arrogance denial and a
misplaced belief and confidence that the
normalcy and comfort of our modern life
will continue indefinitely I know that
because I feel it too and it's hard to
resist so have I changed my tune on this
yes absolutely do I think the world is
coming to an end no I do not do I think
we should panic no nobody does do I
think that the more dire predictions of
millions of people being infected and
many many dying do I think that will
come true I don't know I really don't
I'm not sure but I will go out on not
much of a limb and say that there is
reason for serious concern for us and
reason to make some adjustments to our
lives and and in the way that we conduct
ourselves to protect ourselves and our
loved ones yes that's where I am right
now if it all sounds kind of confused
and contradictory and unhelpful well
then I guess good because I you know I
don't want you coming to me for help on
this I'm not the guy for that no show
host is you shouldn't be going to
anybody no none of us should be going to
someone who gives opinions for living
for advice on something like this all we
could do is listen to what the doctors
and epidemiologists are saying not just
your local pediatrician who isn't
necessarily an expert on viral pandemics
though he sort of knows more than I do
and you do but the men and women who do
this work for a living if we listen to
them look at how governments and
powerful institutions across the world
are handling this at great cost and then
we make up our minds about how we should
treat it and that's the best I think
that we can do at this point
let's move on to some news headlines
number one Bernie Sanders called a press
conference yesterday and most people
thought he was going to drop out but
those people forgot that Bernie Sanders
is an old man obsessed with power and
the sound of his own voice
so they forgot about that and thought he
would drop out he didn't instead he did
this we are winning the generational
debate while Joe Biden continues to do
very well with older Americans
especially those people over 65 our
campaign continues to win the vast
majority of the votes of younger people
and I am talking about people not just
in their 20s but in their 30s and their
40s the younger generations of this
country continue in very strong numbers
to support our campaign so Bernie
staying in this thing he's not going
anywhere
he's not gonna win he really can't win
and his continued presence is only gonna
hurt the eventual nominee Joe Biden who
by the way is a guy who could really use
a break at this point he could really
use some time off his feet as it were
but instead of giving that to him Bernie
is gonna keep harassing him and forcing
him to stay in it and keep arguing which
as a conservative I'm a big fan of I
love the approach if I were a Democrat
I'd be pretty pretty upset but remember
as I always say it requires an immense
amount of ego and self delusion to run
for president in the first place
I mean just thinking to yourself imagine
thinking to yourself seriously I should
be President and I can actually win I
should be in charge of the whole country
I am the guy and I can and and I could
really win - imagine thinking imagine
the narcissism required to have that
thought in your head and in the near
psychotic level of delusion you have to
have to think that you could actually
win now of course it does end up being
true one of those deluded narcissists
will really win and so maybe in the
they weren't so diluted though they're
still narcissistic but that's why this
when we understand that it becomes less
mysterious why a guy like Bernie Sanders
stays in the race acting like a deluded
narcissist to the very end well because
that's what he is and that's why he got
in and that's what's been that's been
the animating force behind his run this
entire time
number two Harvey Weinstein as you
probably heard is going to jail for 23
years convicted of rape he's also going
to be I imagine in solitary confinement
essentially his for his whole time in
prison I would think that although I did
I did recently read that they moved Bill
Cosby out of protective custody and put
him in the general population which is
kind of surprising it seems unlikely
they would do that with Weinstein I
don't know either way an astounding turn
of events for Harvey Weinstein not
astounding at this point the fact that
he's going to jail if you if you're
looking at the last three years the fact
that he's going to jail for rape is not
very astounding but if you go back five
years ten years he was one of the most
powerful people in Hollywood wined and
dined by the world's elites now he's
going to prison as a rapist and he'll
die there in a Cell of course this
should have happened much sooner
and those elites who are wining and
dining him a lot of them should be in
jail with him but the point is evil
doesn't look so glamorous anymore when
it's hobbling into a jail cell as an old
fat broken man to sit there and for the
rest of his life and then eventually die
forgotten and scorned that's that's what
evil gets you number three a bill in
Canada speaking of evil would
criminalize so-called conversion therapy
here's the language of the bill any
practice treatment or service designed
to change an individual's sexual
orientation or gender identity or to
eliminate or reduce sexual attraction or
sexual behavior between persons of the
same sex for greater certainty this
definition does not include a surgical
sex change or any related service so
that's that's how they describe
conversion therapy and the bill would
ban that now in a pretty pretty powerful
testimony against this bill a woman who
used to live as a man recorded a video
that was
was that was going to be presented to
the lawmakers in Canada urging them to
vote against the bill because she's
someone who relied upon so-called
conversion therapy to come to a point
where she's happy and satisfied in her
own body as the person that God made her
here's some of what she had to say
senators of Canada I would encourage you
to vote no on s 202 without the help of
discipleship ministries and counseling I
could not be living in my biological sex
healthy and whole giving those who
struggle with gender confusion hormone
is only treating the symptom and not
treating the real underlying issues in
voting no you would allow hope to
continue for those like me who are
seeking help from counseling or from a
ministry or help through their church
these places are offering healing and
restoration to those who struggle with
unwanted same-sex attraction homeless
sexuality or gender confusion not
conversion therapy now let's think about
this think about a bill that
criminalizes so-called conversion
therapy first of all what happened to
being pro-choice if someone wants to
seek this counseling why shouldn't they
have the choice to do it what you're
really saying with a bill like this is
that a person in the LGBT community
should not be able to find and receive
and choose to receive this sort of
counseling even if they want it how is
that not infantilizing patronizing
controlling also let's focus on the
transgender piece of this because this
is where it's really really evil in my
opinion what the bill seems to be saying
is that if somebody if a man let's say
thinks he's a woman it should be against
the law to help him accept his natural
biological sex to try to relieve him of
this delusion that is destroying his
life and causing him despair and which
he is seeking he's gone to a counselor
seeking to be rid of it what Canada is
saying is no it should be illegal you
can't treat that you can't give him what
he wants
you can't help him if he thinks he's a
he's a woman and he's unhappy with that
delusion and wants to be free of it you
sorry you can't help but it's not
illegal
it's explicitly not illegal to castrate
him so that's what you're allowed to do
he comes to you thinks he's a woman he's
in despair you can castrate him you
can't give him psychological treatment
castration is going to be the only
acceptable treatment option one of the
only acceptable treatment options for
someone with gender dysphoria Canada has
completely lost its mind in conclusion
but actually wait a second here because
let's think about this if a gay man
wants to be a woman becomes a woman
quote-unquote and is still attracted to
men then if his new gender is legitimate
and if we're told he's a woman now
that's what he is well hasn't he just
gone from gay to straight according to
you now he's a woman attract as many as
a straight woman when it went from gay
man straight woman he went from gay to
straight right so isn't that convert
conversion therapy then haven't you
effectively changed his sexual
orientation which you've told us is
impossible to do well you just did it so
you're telling me it's illegal to change
someone's sexual orientation unless you
do it by castration in which case you're
good to go for Sarah Palin was on the
show the masked singer that's the one
where celebrities or former celebrities
come out in masks and sing as the name
would suggest this show is somehow very
popular Sarah Palin showed up and I'll
show you the clip I'm not really sure
the context because I don't watch the
show because I have that IQ over 82 but
so I don't know the context she's
singing but she doesn't have a mask on
so I don't know what I thought she's
supposed of a mask on so here she is
singing or rapping actually and well
here it is watch the artist formerly
known as the bear y'all make some noise
for governor Sarah Palin
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
God's wrath has really come upon this
nation and for good reason very very
very good reason five a bit of a
disturbing tweet I thought from the
Chicago Transit Authority here it is it
says our crews continue to work all
hours of the day to ensure trains buses
and stations are cleaned and disinfected
daily and there's footage of CTA crews
cleaning and scrubbing down the trains
very diligently which is good that's not
the disturbing part that that part is
not disturbing the disturbing part is
the apparent insinuation that they don't
do this every day anyway regardless of a
virus in fact I've become sort of
uncomfortable with that all of the wash
your hands stuff the even tutorials you
find the media newspapers publishing
these how to's on how to wash your hands
I think don't people do that anyway is
anyone learning anything from this I
whose the person who saw a tutorial on
washing your hands in the newspaper and
said oh that's how you do it
and I see people on social media saying
man I'm washing my hands so much now
it's crazy okay but what were you doing
before is my question because you should
be washing your hands frequently
throughout the day anyway not just when
you go to the bathroom but like
throughout the day you should wash your
hands it's just something you should do
good hygiene so I'm glad everybody has
discovered hygiene my point is I hope
that this becomes a habit that outlasts
the virus which may help us prevent
another one number six here's a bonus
store usually I do five but here's a
sixth one I just want to play this for
you this is from Alexandria Kaiser
Cortes one of the I know it sounds
but one of the key parts to preventing
transmission is washing your hands and
not touching your face okay wait a
second I'm what was that banal banal
it's it's banal it's but it's not banal
banal rhymes with canal it's not banal
rhymes with anal now I want to be a
little sympathetic because we've I think
many of us have been in a spot before
where we use a certain word and then
somebody corrects us and tells us that
we mispronounced it and then we think
back and we think oh my goodness I I had
been saying this word wrong my entire
life this is a word I use a lot and I
know what has ever told me I'm
pronouncing it how many people have I
said this to and they thought to
themselves what an idiot had never told
me anything it's kind of like if you're
you know it's like 6:00 p.m. and you
went to the bathroom six hours ago and
somebody says hey your fly's unzipped
and you think you're the first person
that tell me so it's a similar kind of
thing I had that experience recently
when I went to go to a food truck to
order a gyro and I noticed for the first
time I noticed that the guy behind the
counter referred to it as a gyro I think
it's how you pronounce the gyro like
with a Y and I thought is that and then
I looked it up and I know that okay
that's actually what I'm supposed to be
saying gyro not gyro I've been saying
gyro this although and that's a problem
because I love gyros and I eat them all
the time so how many times have I gone
up and said can I have one gyro please
and the person thought what what a dumb
American and never bothered to tell me
although I'm sticking with gyro because
I think you were just sounds weird all
right that was a long story a little bit
banal I'm sorry I'm sorry for that banal
story now finally we'll go to our daily
cancellation bracket have time for the
emails today but we had a couple of good
why I'm wrong email so we'll do those
tomorrow remember you can become a
member
Delhi wired member and and send emails
to the mailbag all right today we have a
rare double cancellation to end with not
just it not not a person being canceled
twice we've done that already but in
this case it's a person being canceled
twice for basically the same infraction
or a related infraction
and here we have Mara Gaye who earns
this distinct honor of the double the
rare double cancellation she was the
woman while just played for you to
remind you she was the woman involved in
this famous rather infamous exchange you
see it as a possibility if he wants to
spend a billion bucks beating this guy
he could do it
absolutely somebody tweeted recently
that actually with the money he spent he
could have given every American a
million dollar got it let's put it up a
screen it when I read it tonight on
social media it kind of all became clear
bloomberg spent 500 million on ads u.s.
population 327 million don't tell us if
you're ahead of us on the math he could
have given each American one million
dollars and have had lunch money left
over
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's an incredible way of putting it
it's true it's disturbing it does it
does suggest you know what we're talking
about here which is there's too much
money in politics so that obviously was
incorrect
they were both off by a factor of about
a million five hundred million divided
by 327 million gives each person a buck
and a half not a million dollars and
that woman Mara gay as well as Brian
Williams both came in for some criticism
a lot of criticism because this is the
internet age and this is what happens
when you say something stupid you're
gonna have 10 million people calling you
stupid it's gonna last about three or
four days probably maybe a little bit
longer in a case of something like this
I've been through it a lot of us have
been through it it's not fun you just
got a ride with it ride it out people
will move on especially these days we're
in the middle of a pandemic people have
other things to talk about so you could
just just go into hiding go into a
bunker it's good anyway if you avoid the
pandemic that way come out in three days
everyone's moved on
well Mara Gaye she didn't want to do
that she didn't wanna play take this in
stride or play along or be
self-deprecating about it so instead how
do you think she handled it what angle
do you think she took what what
narrative that you tried to construct to
explain the criticism well of course we
already know she said that it was racist
she wrote a piece in the New York Times
with the title my people had
in through worse than a Twitter mob when
you're a black woman in America with a
public voice a trivial math error can
lead to a deluge of hate a deluge of
hate I should say a deluge now I'm
making fun of people for I mispronounce
words all the time I'm aware of that and
Here I am making fun of Alexandria kzo
Curtis and she goes on from there to
talk about the racist attacks that she
suffered all the horrible racism the
racist mob that came after she doesn't
never mind the fact that Brian Williams
again is a is a white man and he came in
for the same criticism same exact amount
probably more that doesn't count that
doesn't matter people were criticizing a
black woman so obviously it has to be
racist and sexist - of course she threw
that in there and the moral of the story
according her is that she's a hero
she's Rosa Parks she's a civil rights
martyr actually she's a warrior with
standing courageously all the people on
the internet calling her stupid for
making a math error first of all it was
not a trivial error you were off by a
factor of a million that's not trivial
second no you see Mars that's not how
this works
you said something dumb people reacted
they would have reacted the same if you
were a white man saying it and we know
that because a white man said it too and
he got the exact same reaction and
that's it you might be able to sift
through the thousands of tweets that
came at you laughing at you and find a
couple that had a racist tinge to them
and that's bad they should have done
that but that doesn't make the entire
mob racist if there are 10 million
people making fun of you and three of
them make it into a racial thing you
can't say that the entire ten million
are racist if you want to call them a
bunch of jerks a bunch of petty jerks
who are laughing at you fine I would
agree with that and I'm one of the petty
jerks who laughed at you not racist
though not everything is racist it turns
out all right we're gonna leave it there
and hope you guys all have a great day
stay safe out there probably remember
your social distancing and we'll talk
tomorrow
Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
supervising producer Mathis Glover
supervising producer Robert Stirling
technical producer Austin Stephens
editor Dany D'Amico audio mixer Robin
Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
20 hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host
of the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon has
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Klavan show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew cliff
[Music]